ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاشنا السادس
مراقبه وقلق واجراءات حذره واستباقيه من
تكرار سيناريو لم ينساه العلم بعد من
دولتين افريقيتين قد تبدا البدايه لشيء
كبير ربما غينيا الاستوائيه وتنزانيا
تواجهان اول تفشي معروف لفيروس مارفل وهو
حمى نزفيه فيروسيه شديده العدوى رقعه
الاصابه بدات في الاتساع وهو ما دفع دولا
عده من بينها دول خليجيه الى اصدار توصيات
بشان السفر اليهما تجنبا للاصابه بالفيروس
المميت هذا الاسبوع حتى المراكز الامريكيه
لمكافحه الامراض والوقايه منها المسافرين
الى البلدين على تجنب الاختلاط بالمرضى
ومراقبه الاعراض لمده ثلاثه اسابيع بعد
مغادره المنطقه غينيا الاستوائيه الواقعه
على الساحل في غرب افريقيا اعلنت تفشي
فيروس ماربرد في منتصف فبراير الفائت وفي
22 من مارس كان لدى غينيا الاستوائيه 13
حاله
مؤكده بما في ذلك تسعه اشخاص لقوا حتفهم
بينما تعافى شخص واحد وفقا لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه اما تنزانيا الواقعه على الساحل
في شرق افريقيا بدا الفيروس بالتفشي فيها
منذ مارس الفائت حيث سجلت ثمان حالات
مؤكده بما في ذلك خمس حالات وفاه
بعد كورونا فيروس ماربرج يثير الرعب في
العالم
اعراض فيروس الصداع والحمى والم العضلات
بعدها يعاني المصاب من اسهال والام في
المعده وغثيان وطفح جلدي معدلات الوفيات
بفيروس تتراوح بين
24% الى
88% يموت المصاب بعد ثمانيه الى تسعه ايام
بسبب النزيف الحاد والصدمه فيروس شديد
العدوى من عائله فيروس ايبولا الفتاك مصاب
يظهر المصاب بملامح شبحيه عينان عميقتان
ووجه بلا ملامح فيروس ومربرج هل من علاج
حتى اللحظه لا يوجد علاج او لقاح محدد
للفيروس
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من دار
السلام الصحفي
الدكتور منى كياله طبيبه الاستشاريه في
تشخيص الامراض الجرثوميه والفيروسيه في
المستشفى الجامعي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
دكتوره ساعود لك بعد قليل لفهم المخاوف
لفهم هذا التفشي ولكن اسمحي لي ان ابدا مع
ضيفي من دار السلام لنقف على الصوره
الحقيقيه يعني سيد ايزيك الى اي مدى هناك
تفشي حقيقي كيف هي الصوره ما التفاصيل من
عندكم
في السادس عشر من شهر مارس الحكومه هنا
اصدرت بيانا
تحدثت فيه عن وجود فيروس كان لابد من
تحديده في تلك الفتره وقالوا ان هناك بعض
ثمانيه مرضى لديهم بعض الاعراض المتعلقه
بالفيروس لكنهم لم يكونوا يعرفون انذاك
بانه
تسعه ايام
اصدرت الحكومه بيانا اخرا وقالت فيه بانها
اكدت ان الفيروس هو ماربر هو ان ثماني
اشخاص قد اصيبوا بهذا الفيروس خمسه منهم
ماتوا انذاك ولذا في من تلك الفتره بدات
تعقب مخالطين بالمرضى للوقوف على كل من
كان على اتصال مع اولئك الافراد
واجراء عمليات الحجر الطبي وهذا وقد تم
حجر ما يزيد عن خمسه اشخاص لكن في الفتره
الحديث التي نتحدث فيها قد ارتفع الرقم
الى 2011 شخصا واخر معلومات حصلنا عليها
هي ان يصل الى 35 شخصا قد تم
الافراج عنهم او الذهاب الى منازلهم بعد
ان اكم اكملوا واحدا وعشرين يوما من الحجر
الصحي والمراقبه الامر هذا هو
بواقعها الذي وتقول الحكومه بانه ما من
حالات جديده لفيروس مارفل
الى جانب متابعه او تتبع المرضى تتبع
تحركاتهم الى جانب الفحوص السريريه هل
هناك بعض الاجراءات الاحترازيه في تنزانيا
مثلا
وفقا لما تقوله الحكومه
للتصريحات الصادره عنها
بانهم بانهم ياخذون هذا الامر على محمل
الجد وفعل سبيل المثال كانوا قد اصدروا
تحذيرات بالسفر للمسافرين القادمين
والخارجين من البلاد بالنسبه للدخل
للقادمين الى البلاد يجب ان يخضعوا
الاختبارات
وفحوصات ومراقبه درجه الحراره
وتعبئه نموذجا للسماح لهؤلاء القادمين
للدخول الى البلاد وبعد ذلك سوف يعطونا
رقما مجانيا للابلاغ عن اي اعراض قد تكون
مشابهه لاعراض لفيروس مارفل وفي ذات الوقت
تقوم الحكومه باصدار المعلومات ولا سيما
في مجال
في في
المجالات المتعلقه ليس فقط في غرب اسمح لي
على المقاطعه اعلم بانها ترجمه ولكن لضيق
الوقت ساعتذر منك سنعود لك في حلقات قادمه
يبدو بان الموضوع سيطول اشكرك جزيل الشكر
لوكاندو الصحفي من دار السلام بقيه الوقت
ساكمله معك يا دكتوره منى لمحاوله فهم هذه
المخاوف اولا نحن نتحدث عن تفاشي هل ينتقل
من تفشي الى مرحله الجائحه
مساء الخير استاذ ريم وتحياتي لك وللساده
المشاهدين
يعني من المستبعد يعني من المستبعد دائما
وهو ليس بالفيروس الجديد يعني مستني 67
قليله صارت هيدي يعني
لماذا دقت منظمه الصحه العالميه نقوذ
الخطر
منظمه الصحه العالميه دائما تدق ناقوس
الخطر بولا عندما ينتشر التفشيات اليوم
لانه اكبر تفشي في السنين الاخيره
وهناك يعني خصوصا في غينيا الاستوائيه
اليوم في عدد حالات كبير ودائما تذوق
ناقوس الخطر حتى نكون يعني متحضرين وهي
تهدف الى يعني الاستثمار في لقاح في مثل
هذه الامراض التي تنتشر في القاره
من بين مخاوف الاخرى حضرتك تقولين بانه
هذا الفيروس طريقه العدوى صعبه ولكن هذا
الفيروس هو من عائله الايبولا والايبولاك
سميت جائحه بين 2014 و 2016 وفتكت باكثر
من 11,000 وهنا المخاوف الحقيقيه هل يمكن
لهذا الفيروس ان يعيشنا لا قدر الله طبعا
ما عاشه البعض بما يخص
طبعا هو فيروس مخيف يعني هو من الفيروسات
اللي هي منظمه الصحه العالميه تضعهم في
قائمه الفيروسات الاخطر القائمه المجموعه
رقم اربعه وايضا في مجموعه اخرى الامريكيه
من السي دي سي اللي هي
يعني الالف اللي هي الاكثر خطوره يعني من
الناحيه البيولوجيه كونه فيروس خطير جدا
مسبب للوفاه ولا علاج له وايضا لا لقاح له
فبالتالي هو مخيف يعني خطير جدا وبالتالي
نحن نخاف طبعا من من انتقاله ولكن بنضل
بنقول انه للناس اللي في بيوتها يعني في
مثنى العربي انه نحن اليوم يعني خارج
المنطقه
الاستيطان المرض
استوقفتني جمله قلتيها باختصار شديد
الكورونا 19 اكثر من 20 تلقيح هذا الفيروس
المرعب اكتشف في 67 والى اليوم تقولين ليس
هناك تلقيح باختصار شديد
اليس هناك تلقيح لانه عدد الاصابات كان
قليل خلال كل تاريخ وايضا كونه في افريقيا
انتهت توقيت هذه الحلقه دكتوره ولكن ستكون
لنا لقاءات اخرى من برا الدكتوره منى كيال
الطبيبه الاستشاريه في تشخيص الامراض
الجرثوميه السلام عليكم